My name is Julia Pian.
I'm originally from San Diego, California.
I went to Harvard College for undergrad...
...and I'm now a third year medical student at Harvard Medical School.
Typically, I start a day anywhere from 6 to 7:30, I'll wake up...
...and basically head straight into the hospital.
I'll often check on the patients that I'm working with...
...and see how their night went and then I join rounds,...
...which is where we go with a whole team of attendings, resident physicians,...
...as well as medical students, sometimes nurses as well.
We go and we see every patient kind of tell their story...
...and figure out what the plan is for the rest of the day.
The rest of the day kind of varies honestly.
Sometimes, I'll go with the attendings to clinic...
...where I'll see patients in the outpatient setting.
Sometimes, like right now, I'm on my surgery rotation, I'll go to the operating room...
...and see some really interesting cases.
And then sometimes, I'll stay on the floor with the residents...
...and take care of the patients in the hospital,...
...maybe do little procedures there as well.
It really varies what time you get home depending on how busy it is.
But once I'm home, I try and do a mix of studying and relaxing...
...and preparing for the next day.
So maybe I'll start by watching an episode of my favorite TV show...
...and then do a little bit of reading and practice questions for upcoming tests.